[MUSIC]
My name is Donald Hicks,
I currently lead the global support
operations team here at twitter,
my whole professional journey has been one
that's been unpredictable and exciting.
I would love to tell you the journey
going from hardware to software and
platform support was one that
was really well thought out and
it was calculated, it actually wasn't.
Leaning on the work and the experiences I
got out of SCP, I felt like I was better
able to show up and in a more positive way
when I joined here, and more importantly,
I was just more confident in it.
Heck, it was okay not to know and
to fail fast, and
these are all the ideas that they
reinforce with any program prior to SCP,
you could best describe me as a
hard-working mercenary, take no prisoners.
Focused primarily on
ascending in my career,
when I was a part of SCP you get
the opportunity to refine your academic,
sort of understanding of key terms and
frame works?
You get an opportunity to be introduced
to newer coaches like negotiation,
SCP give me the licence,
the permission to take a pause, and
really learn about me and
sort of rediscover what makes me whole.
And when you take that moment,
it evokes a lot of different emotions,
nervousness, fear, excitement,
it reminded me of how closed off I
really was as a leader, and what was
really refreshing was understanding
that I was not alone in my emotions.
And that a lot of my classmates,
whether they had different roles or
jobs as me all walked around in their
profession with the same set of emotions,
the feeling of isolation, since the
program, I have evolved as a leader and
hopefully as a better leader.
It's okay to make mistakes,
learn fast for some of your failures and
experiment again, coming out of
the program, I was able to make a huge
pivot toward choosing a job that
helped me make an impact in the world.
[MUSIC]